[Music]
Where, for example, would you like me to turn the gardens around the world with
a half-bar, if it is a long distance away, in the heart of the
roundabout globally, Bahrain Three Roundabout? The important thing is that it
is far from the
strong buildings, and we live in a
high-rise building, meaning a sixth floor. It is no longer good
for us to sleep in the houses because of the tremors that are
happening and the earthquakes, meaning we are afraid.  For the children, I
mean, there will be destruction or the building will be demolished. We have been
sleeping in the car right on the
road.
[Music] [
Music] [
Applause]
I have
diabetes and a comb. I run. Look, I am empty of diabetes. I
took care of helpless men and did
not come out. I
[Music] I brought the
tent 150,
thank God.  Lord of the worlds, the concern has come, but it has not come
to the people
[music]